just say you know I'm gonna have
spoilers in this review cuz I just kind
of don't feel like talking about this
movie without spoilers so it's a spoiler
movie now hereditary so hereditary is a
slow burn in d'art house feeling horror
movie or ghost movie haunting movie
possession movies long story short the
grandmother of this family dies the mom
is dealing with that grief the family's
kind of there they have tension between
I'm trying to dazzle your kid in
flammable chemicals almost lighting them
on fire schizophrenia or not gonna cause
a little tension the point is as the
grief is settling in among the tension
in the family creepy things start
happening and then escalating until the
end of the movie I'm gonna get right
into it toni collette was great in this
movie I've heard so much about this
movie some of which I agree with some of
which I don't but the thing I absolutely
positively do agree with and I feel like
a lot of people are going to is that she
was awesome
she needs to be intense she is she needs
to be a little unsettling she is just
come across as a little crazy she does I
do hope the Academy does keep her in the
conversation when Oscar season comes
around more than they did McAvoy for
split cuz I thought he was great in that
too but this movie does it does go for
the slow burn which is code for saying
it was kind of boring and it was kind of
boring it goes for the slow burn it
knows it's boring it's not exciting it's
not like pins and needles
edge-of-your-seat intensity all the time
and yeah it doesn't rely on jump scares
earlier on in the movie the lights are
off and she looks in the dark and in the
darkness you kind of see a shape and it
takes your eyes a moment to adjust and
you're like oh that's a figure that's a
person almost like that a really creepy
to me and it's psychological warfare at
that point I like it when the movie did
that most of the movie doesn't boil down
to creepy things or seeing things in the
dark most of the movie boils down to
you're hanging out with this family but
I feel like the board collective is
likely the Borg we love this movie and
you must do I liked it I didn't love it
not as much as I've heard I should which
is an interesting thing for me to say
since I give this movie all the props in
the world for really doing it right
you've heard it a hundred times how
horror movies are cliche this movie's
not closed yet you've heard it a million
and a half times that's hyperbole but
the main phrases when people talk about
horror movies is that it was predictable
and it relied on jump scares this movie
does not rely on jump scares nor is it
predictable least for the first half
first half of the movie wasn't
predictable second half I felt was
pretty predictable I mean my jaw was
dropped on the floor when the girl is
having a nut allergy sticks her head out
the window and smacks her head on a pole
I was like oh [ __ ] because we thought it
was gonna be creepy little girl doing
creepy little girl things in the ghost
movie we've seen that a hundred
all right I guess not they just smoked
her she's smoked and the look on the
son's face of him being frozen to the
point of being nammed that was effective
I really like that's moments like that
to stick out with me which is why
there's such steep contrast between that
amazing scene in his acting and the
scene where he cries when they're doing
the seance and he cries his fake cries a
little weird I didn't like it but that
scene was a little girls heads and his
reaction I know that dudes a good actor
I've seen some reviews where reviewers
and critics are like this was the
scariest movie holy [ __ ] in the world
where I feel like this movie should
scare me maybe I'm a callous human being
I was never scared in the movie I found
the movie interesting couple of times
was like a couple of times my jaw drops
as for me this movie didn't scare me as
much as the general populace who've seen
it or at least reviewed it the movie
does have affective disturbing imagery
but disturbing imagery doesn't scare me
necessarily fossil has disturbing
imagery I wouldn't call it some sort of
horror masterpiece and at this movie in
hostel not exactly comparable not in
terms of directing general competence
I'm just illustrating that disturbing
and/or gore doesn't mean scary to me
maybe that's just me but there's my
review everything in this video was just
my take the ending had some creepy-ass
seems like when she's banging her head
on the trapdoor in the ceiling I really
like that that's when the [ __ ] goes down
but really from there to the end I just
knew where it was gonna go partly
because this felt like a modern-day
version of the witch and it ends a lot
like the witch in the witch the entire
family is killed off and the surviving
youth gets to hang out with the demon
and basically evil wins in hereditary
the entire family is killed off and the
surviving youth gets to hang out with
the demon and basically evil wins and
he's possessed by the demon so it's a
little different but in the way it plays
out I felt like it was a lot the same
basic that's what I can say about the
movies if you didn't like the witch
you're probably not gonna like this
movie in tone pace and execution I felt
like there were a lot to say Brennan in
this movie they don't talk like they're
speaking from the King James Bible but I
felt like it went for a lot of the same
kind of tone I would have found it more
interesting if the ending wasn't so
absolute if it was just riddled in
nuance I mean I've seen a few people
address the fact that hereditary could
mean the bloodline that is linked to
this demon or the occult or hereditary
could mean through bloodline you passed
down mental illness like schizophrenia
but the ending really doesn't go with
that if the ending was more open to be
like alright was it a demon or was this
schizophrenia it could be either I find
that more interesting by the end of this
movie you have no choice but to be like
nah demon did that but in the end I do
feel like
hereditary is one of those movie she
should watch at least one smell like
this movie did go in a different
direction I appreciate that I really
liked that I didn't blow a load over
this movie like a lot of people have but
I appreciated what they did it doesn't
do the slow burn as well as old-school
Shyamalan day but it's also not teenage
horror movies flock [ __ ] nonsense and in
the end I will say hereditary was a good
time to alcohol required if you don't
watch it now you're gonna take a film
class in which case the teacher will
show it to you later and then give you a
quiz you might as well watch it now so
you can nap in class when they do that
alright so who ready Terry have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]